a bartender robbed at gunpoint is forced
to pay back the thousands of dollars
that was stolen now the video obtained
by the 8 news now i-team showing the
moment his life changed forever and now
he's talking exclusively to our i-team
as he plans to sue his former employer
our own David Charles here now with the
interview you will only see on eight
news now David yeah Brian Denise you may
have heard about this story on social
media when Edward Parker first talked
about this robbery and his repayment to
the bar where he worked tonight he and
his attorneys have filed a lawsuit
asking a judge to decide if this bar
should be punished
a quiet Friday morning inside the lodge
Hualapai quickly turning violent when an
armed gunman storms in demanding cash
the bartender with his hands up is 42
year old Edward Parker it's December
2020. we're in the middle of covid
people are fighting for jobs left and
right
I suppose I let the idea of having a
steady job with steady income cloud my
judgment cloud is Judgment he says
because hours after handing over 3 900
Parker says his employer told him he had
to pay the money back I wasn't thinking
right I just had a gun shoved in my face
and I signed the document this document
a signed contract saying 300 would come
out of his paycheck until the full
amount
3937.35 was all paid off what was the
time between when you were robbed and
when you signed that document three to
four hours tops Parker now lives out of
state his attorneys say the lodge
coerced him to sign that contract it's a
demand for repayment for money that was
taken from him it's the most outrageous
thing I've ever seen and it's not right
he allowed this arm to sail in to come
in do what he was threatening to do and
leave without without getting himself
hurt or without getting any of the
patrons who actually were there hurt so
he did everything right his employer did
everything wrong after paying back the
money in those installments Parker says
he was fired after taking an approved
vacation I was devastated I loved that
company I'd worked very hard for them I
couldn't believe they had done this to
me
devastated he says he hopes the lawsuit
proves no employee is too small and that
business owners particularly in the
restaurant industry will be held
accountable I'm hoping to show them that
I can lead by example and if you guys
have problems with employers don't be
afraid to speak up you're not alone out
there
now the good news is police did find the
robber charging him for a string of
incidents across the valley the State
Labor Commission facilitated a
settlement with Parker and the lodge for
fifty five hundred dollars which his
lawyers say he did not accept we did
reach out to the lodge and did not hear
back I'm David charns live local now